, THE NASDAQ FELL ALMOST
TOO.
>> INTO KNIGHT’S DEMOCRACY 2020
REPORT, THE VASTLY DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES FOR THE TOO MAJOR
PARTIES AS THEY PREPARE FOR
THEIR SUMMER CONVENTIONS.
REPUBLICANS WANT TO THROW A
PARTY.
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO KEEP IT
MOSTLY DIGITAL.
CORRESPOND OR PETER DUCEY TELLS
US TONIGHT FROM MARYLAND THAT
THAT DEMOCRATIC TACTICS COULD
EXTEND THROUGHOUT MUCH OF THE
CAMPAIGN.
>> IF JOE BIDEN IS ELECTED
PRESIDENT, HE’S HINTING AT AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT WOULD READ
SOMETHING LIKE THIS BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME BY THE IT
IS HERE BY ORDERED AS FOLLOWS,
EVERYONE MUST WEAR A FACE MASK.
>> YOU WOULD IN EFFECT MANDATE
THE WEARING OF MASK.
>> I WOULD DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO MAKE IT REQUIRED
THAT PEOPLE HAD TO WEAR THE MASK
IN PUBLIC.
>> AS THEY PLOW AHEAD WITH A
LARGE IN PERSON CONVENTION IN
JACKSONVILLE THIS SUMMER.
THEY ARE DELAYING THE NEXT PHASE
OF REOPENING AMID A SPIKE IN
COVERT CASES, BIDEN SAYS IT’S
PROBABLE TO ACCEPT THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION, IT WILL
BE IN AN EMPTY ROOM.
IT DOESN’T TAKE ANY LARGE
CAMPAIGN RALLIES ARE IN THE
CARDS BETWEEN NOW AND ELECTION
DAY BREAD.
>> IF THE RALLIES WERE UNDER
CONTROL AND WE COULD TALK ABOUT
THE VACCINE OR WE HAD WAYS IN
WHICH TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS WAS
NOT BEING TRANSMITTED, THEN YES,
BUT I DON’T SEE THAT HAPPENING.
>> THURSDAY A GROUP OF INVITED
GUESTS AND A SMALL PRESS POOL TO
MINIMIZE SOCIAL DISTANCING.
BUT THEY WERE SHUT OUT AND THEIR
EDITORIAL BOARD IS NOT HAPPY.
BY SHUTTING LMT LIEN AGAINST HER
ONLINE OUT OF A COMPUTE
COMMUNITY HEALTH DISCUSSION, THE
CAMPAIGNS IN THE WRONG MESSAGE
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF LOCAL
JOURNALISM TO THE VERY
COMMUNITIES IT IS TRYING TO
REACH DURING THE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
THEIR NETWORK BE CUT OUT AT WHAT
SOUNDED LIKE QUITE AN
OVERESTIMATION.
>> NOW WE HAVE OVER 120 MILLION
DEAD FOR COVERT.
>> THAT IS WHERE THE VIDEO THIS
AFTERNOON AND AUDIO RECORDING
HAS SURFACED AND HAVE
IMMEDIATELY THERE HAVE BEEN
120,000 DEAD.